let's consider the motion of an object  that is under the action of a force so  we have some force that's acting on this  object and we have a little displacement  D s so this is a small displacement of  the object then we know that the small  amount of work done by the action of  this force is f dot d s and the rate of  doing work  so let's now introduce the concept of  power which is the rate of doing work  that is f dot DS over DT and D s DT is  just the velocity of the object so we  see very simply that when we talk about  power and sometimes people use the  symbol P although we can also talk about  pressure and momentum so it's a little  bit tricky but here the power is f dot V  and power is a concept that will appear  in many different settings